Hey! Welcome back to our very last segment
of the very last lecture of
functional programming 101 and in
this last
segment, I am going to make up for
some clowny code
that we wrote a couple of lectures ago.
I don't know if you remember
but when we were talking about list
comprehensions
we wrote a really really
really embarrassing version
of a prime number generator. And
we want to do better. That code was not
the most beautiful code I have written
in my life. So let's redeem ourselves
and write a beautiful way to generate
primes
that leverages lazy evaluation. Here is a
recipe to generate an infinite list of
primes
in a very
nice way. We start with the list
of all natural numbers, starting at 2,
and then
we look in this list and we mark the
first
value in that list as a prime.
So the first prime here is 2. The next
thing we do
is we say: okay, if we know that this
thing is a prime
then all multiples of that
number are not primes. So for example
4 is a multiple of 2
so we know that 4 is not a prime number.
Given the first marked prime
we are going to delete, we are going to
filter out all the multiples of that
number from the list.
And then we note that then
the next value is the prime and then we
delete all the duplicates and so on.
This algorithm is really old.
This algorithm was really invented
before
any of us was
born. And this is called
the sieve of Eratosthenes. So this was
invented by ancient Greek
mathematicians. Let's draw the picture
here
of a few of these steps. We start here
with the list of natural numbers
starting at 2.
First number here is a prime, so
we cross out all the multiples of 2.
So we cross out 4, 6, 8, 10, 12
et cetera. And now the first number
that is not crossed out, 3 is a prime,
that's a prime.
4 was already crossed out; 5 is not a
multiple of 3; 6 is a multiple of 3
was already crossed out;
9 was not crossed out yet, is a
multiple of 3, so we cross that out
and we continue. So now 5 is
the next prime. We are going to remove all
multiples of 5 et cetera. So here you see
that fairly easily we find the first
few prime numbers 2, 3, 5
7 and 11. Let's
translate this into Haskell.
And the beauty of this is that this
algorithm is more or less directly
translated
into Haskell. Of course
again, there is a huge
field of literature on different
versions of this sieve and more efficient
versions.
You can spend years researching that.
It is a beautiful area, but this is the
simplest version of this and to
show you the power
of lazy evaluation and infinite lists.
We start here with the infinite
list of natural numbers starting at 2
and then we are going to
sieve out all these numbers, just
following that recipe.
So how does this sieve work? Well, we start
with the first number in the list, that is
a prime
and what we do is we return that
number
and then we say
throw out all the multiples of p
from xs and then recursively
go back to step 2, sieve out all the
numbers from there.
Isn't that beautiful?
Here is a quite imperative
description, return to step 2, but what
we see here
is that return to step 2 is really
this recursive call here. So we start
with the
numbers from 2 and up, the first number
must be prime
we remove all the numbers that are
duplicate
and then we just sieve the result. That
must now start with the next prime.
We are going to keep that
and then sieve out the rest et cetera.
You can also see
why there are more efficient versions and
we already saw that here
because multiples of 2
are eliminated and here multiples of 2
are eliminated and so
there are many ways you can do this sieve
in a more efficient way, with wheels and
whatever. Again, I would just google for
sieve of Eratosthenes and you will find
a large collection of papers that
describe
different variants of this, that are much
more efficient
and that use all properties of
natural numbers
to make this computation more efficient.
But if we execute this, primes
this thing will just spew out an
infinite list
of prime numbers. It will just continue and
after a while it will get slower and slower
because the prime numbers
there will be more space between them.
But you can just run it forever, and if
you have enough patience
you will find the prime number
that you are looking for.
Since this is an infinite list
it is not really an infinite list,
because it is a recipe for generating
an infinite list.
If we only take the first 10 prime
numbers
this function will terminate
and just give us the first 10 prime
numbers. It won't first compute all prime
numbers, no.
It will just do enough work to give you
the first 10
prime numbers. Or if we want to take the
prime numbers that are less than 15
we can use takeWhile and again
just enough work will be done
to do that. Imagine that you are
in an imperative language or in a
strict language
now you have to choose whether you want
to take the first
primes or you want to take primes up to
a certain number
because you cannot do this in this
modular way.
So you cannot first compute the primes or
have a promise to compute the primes
and then take the first 10 and then
use that very same
description of computing primes and then
take
all the ones that are less than 15.
You have to immediately fuse...
let me see if I can...
it is too hard to not stand in
front, but
you want to fuse take 10 with
primes into one function
and takeWhile less than a certain value
with primes
to get one function if you don't have
lazy evaluation.
A very nice paper to read here
is John Hughes paper "Why Functional
Programming Matters" that has many more
examples
of the fact that lazy evaluation
makes your code more modular. Okay.
That was the end of the lecture series.
I enjoyed it enormously.
I hope you did so too.
And please try to
use everything you learned here to
become
a better programmer and I'm pretty sure
that is the case.
And I hope to see you in another MOOC
at another time. Thank you so much
and again see you soon.
Bye bye.